let me pop open this go ahead and pop
that
oh is that spin drift is that coffee
yeah i'm glad you're drinking coffee
what time is it
309. i'm good with that great good i
need good i just need seven hours to get
it out of my system my cutoff's at four
i'm going to drink a lemon okay drift
right yeah what time you've got brought
to you by lemons brought to you by
lemons lemons
you know we're still a thing well here
we are episode three
yep of our podcast yeah nailing it so
far do you think we lost what percentage
of the audience do you think we lost
after listening to those first two we
stuck in for 14 years of the show
but after two episodes of the podcast
we're out yeah we're out yeah many
people are going to realize that they
just don't give a [ __ ] about what we
have to say but that's okay that's all
right we might be ruining the show this
is a lot like the show where we're just
talking all over each other well how
about this for our listeners that are
like is this all they're gonna do they
will be excited to hear we have a guest
today
that guest is mr michael jordan so if
you're a fan of basketball
it turns out michael jordan's a big
[ __ ] fan and
so stick around um um hey guys oh my god
michael jordan isn't here are we as oh
he isn't no are you son of a [ __ ] she's
probably never seen the show but i'm a
fan what about michael b jordan can we
get him also a fan no he's not available
we're not going to get any of the
michael jordan he's not all right that's
fine listen guys are we ever going to do
an introduction of some kind to this
show are we just going to just launch
right into it there's never any like hey
guys welcome to the zombie sunny
philadelphia podcast it's great to have
you here we got another episode for you
today we're gonna do episode three of
season one
you know anything like that because you
clicked on it you know you pulled it up
you clicked on it if you don't know what
you're listening to by now well can i
fire one off just in case you just did
you just did i guess i didn't yeah
welcome to episode three of the it's
always sunny in philadelphia podcast we
got the whole cast here we got rob
mcelhoney we got charlie dave we got
glenn howerton we do not have caitlyn
olson we do not have danny devito so we
don't have the whole cast and that's
okay so basically the premise of this
whole thing is we just talk and talk and
talk and talk and talk and talk talk
talking talking talking talking talking
talk talk talk talk talk until you can't
[ __ ] stand us anymore it took no time
for that coffee to shoot right in your
system right you took a sip and
immediately
good i'm glad you did it though you
became the micro machine you're gonna be
more fun last week you're just talking
about how tired you are yeah oh no i'm
still tired it's both
it's both it's me it's maybe yeah it is
it is mania i'm not tired today though
we're getting a real real good look into
what this process is like yeah so we get
into the writer's room we spent how long
do we spend doing this crap before we
actually start working on an episode of
the show for people who are turning in
because they're like oh we know what's
the process you don't tune into a
podcast for people who are clicking on
sure because they uh they really are
curious about our process
it's a lot of this
it is it's a lot of things it's 15 16
years of this it bears fruit we have to
create space for conversations that have
nothing to do seemingly with the episode
that we're trying to break only to
sometimes
find something within that conversation
stories about what our day was like what
our weekend was like what the morning
routine was what have you it's probably
why our later episodes are so much
better than our earliest episodes where
again we were just trying to find the
show but we didn't spend a ton of time
talking about them we would just sort of
discuss lightly and then just go write
them yeah yeah yeah maybe well i cannot
recall it was so long ago i have no
recollection of working on that episode
what season one shooting it yes but like
writing it i don't remember right well
that's because i mean in those early
seasons we didn't have offices our show
was so cheap to make and our budget was
so small that we didn't even know to ask
for offices
you know our line producer just kind of
let that slide by because it helped him
save money so we were writing out of our
apartments and out of our manager's
office at 3 arts entertainment until we
got kicked out so we got kicked out of
there because they were sick of us
we were just drinking their coffee i
watched that episode and i i'm very
annoyed by those people i'm very annoyed
by myself yeah what's up
well i just i don't like that show
i don't like that show that that one i
don't know well i wouldn't i wouldn't
keep watching that show if that was the
first episode
i like that that's one of the like i i
actually like that i remember i remember
liking it i remember thinking oh this is
really funny i mean again this is a 2005
or something like that but i remember
caitlyn being really funny i remember
loving like what you guys are and the
classic tammy stuff is great i remember
feeling like we were sort of like
hitting a stride with that episode
feeling as though okay this is clicking
even though it was the third episode we
aired it was one of the later episodes
that were written it was like maybe one
second the last episode that was written
remember there i don't recall that yeah
it was one i remember writing it really
quickly yeah yeah and like all those
names in there there are those are all
your high school buddies right yeah yeah
and we really did smash nicki potne's
car into a tree yeah can i clear
something up for everybody like once and
for all
the waitress's name is not nikki potnick
so stop it it just isn't it doesn't even
make any sense that's a theory that's
been out there for a really long time
that i would like to dispel the
waitress's name
is not nikki potnick that's picky not
nick
[Laughter]
it was kind of fun the way people kind
of came up with that because there was
there was the episode where danny takes
the nikki potnick high school sticker
yep and then the waitress shows waitress
so people said oh they're doing a kind
of a sneaky thing but we weren't that
clever no actually that was a mistake we
just thought it was funny to bring back
the idea of nikki potnick through having
frank put the sticker on and then
totally separate joke that had nothing
to do with that was that even the people
on the committee didn't know the
waitress's name or forgot like that's
how that's how [ __ ] unmemorable she
she was to everyone yep yeah
[Laughter]
you brought up uh caitlyn's drunk acting
as far as i'm concerned she puts on a
clinic in that episode for like comedic
drunk acting i mean that [ __ ] is so so
[ __ ] funny i mean that she really
looks like was she drunk no she wasn't
no no that's i mean that it's so real
it's so real that's kind of people ask a
lot like do you guys just get like drunk
like on the show all the time doing the
scenes and you're like no first of all
it's 7 30 in the morning on like a
wednesday and you're doing that scene
and then you have to do five other
scenes from different episodes in which
you may or may not be drunk then you
have to drive home we've definitely been
drunk when we did or at least i was
drunk when we did the live show i
remember oh yeah pretty hammered when we
were doing the live shows you know what
i couldn't get a hammer i'm doing a live
show because i have such a tenuous grasp
on my own voice as it is that like if i
was drunk i'd be like i can't my voice
is gone uh yeah i was getting pretty
hammered
yeah yeah yeah but then but then like no
when we're shooting i don't think i've
i've ever been drinking while we're now
absolutely [ __ ] getting that only
when
yeah there have been some other times
too but that's okay we don't have to get
into it no i don't really don't even
remember you really don't remember or
just you're not just making that up for
liability purposes yeah
that's a sign of alcoholism you can't
remember i've got a pretty good memory i
thought about it well i will say this we
it's not something that we've done in a
very long time it's some of those really
early seasons it would be like oh it's
the last scene of the day yeah we're
drinking a beer in the bar let's just
have one oh yeah at the end i'm not
talking about getting drunk but i also
remember actually in the gang get
stranded in the woods we were out
shooting at night and we were out in the
woods and i remember us going to get in
a six-pack and
drinking
to shoot one seat yeah wasn't that crazy
yeah you have like a beer too but you're
not loaded no no you get a little bit
looser and have a little fun because
it's a night shoot and you know that's
about it but uh no we weren't getting
hammered or anything like that we should
do that more though this season well
season 15. you know there's the
alcoholic and you speaking
yeah yeah there he
was serious i is drinking a beer with my
grandma and the scene where i'm playing
the piano
with the red hat ladies in philly but we
have so many episodes to talk about and
and and so much time well let's see yeah
let's focus on this one sorry rob i've
got a question for you okay buddy
because it's a subject that comes up in
this episode
rob why don't you tell us what lemon
hill is
lemon hill is a real place in fairmount
park in philadelphia where we used to go
to drink after school okay tell us
i feel like i'm talking about my
drinking quite a bit already this might
be this might be a bit of an
intervention hey man listen yeah here it
comes that's okay so rob so listen uh
for us we would go there after after
school like on fridays and the cops
wouldn't bother us and that's where so
they so it was sort of known and
understood and as long as you guys kept
it together and then didn't go super
nuts the cops just let it happen pretty
much yeah and then and then there would
be was it it was just a park yeah it was
like an area in the park and it would
overlook the river was actually quite
beautiful
river yeah but then there would be there
yeah every once in a while there'd be a
fight that would break out or something
some kind of some kind of violence and
then the cops would come and be like all
you have to do all you have to do is
just not fight it's not fine because
then no one's going to get hurt but
meanwhile everybody's getting in their
cars and driving home so i don't know
what the [ __ ] they were thinking
nevertheless i think they kind of felt
like we were somewhat more responsible
than if this is the in the middle of the
city of philadelphia i think they had
other things yeah they were they were
busy with other things in the city of
philadelphia there was other stuff going
on i found a dead body there yeah oh
yeah tell us about that
that was years later
that was years later and that was what
the cops i'm assuming were spending most
of their time now was that because you
were returning to the scene of the crime
i was no no i was oh no i was driving by
okay driving by and there was very
clearly so you don't you don't remember
killing him
man a woman a child it was a man it
wasn't here it was a man it was a man
who's who was shot yeah oh a shot man
how do you know he was how do you
because i saw his brains blown out of
his face because he did it because he
could have been bludgeoned
that's good that's true he kind of
detected for you fair enough yeah fair
enough yeah well um that's a that's a
fun story
did it completely and totally traumatize
you or were you already hardened to that
sort of thing uh
no it didn't i don't know why it didn't
that's the story are you erotically
aroused i was not arrested were you
aroused be honest no you can be honest
on a podcast i felt nothing i felt sad i
felt sad for the person who was the
recipient of that lie you didn't give a
[ __ ] you didn't give a [ __ ]
did you i didn't care you were amused
and you had something to brag about i
don't know i definitely was not was not
amused
oh god you guys already knew about this
i've tried i've seen it of course but
this has also been amused by the way you
and i charlie and i walked in and saw a
dead body
while we're shooting while we're
shooting in philly what happened tell me
that i don't remember like i just i
this was season three okay and we were
shooting in kensington which is uh oh a
lovely neighborhood but yeah how did we
describe it it's tough it's it's it's
yeah it's rough it's a little rough it's
not doing hot it's a little rough and uh
costumes right was like hey your costume
changed we're switching from scene to
scene they're like your costume change
for the other scene is in that little
house
and we must have gotten the wrong house
so rob and i walked we just walked you
just we just walked in to
and there was like a dead
a teenager yeah in a casket in a casket
oh oh okay
oh okay good it's almost well
it opened
that's better than just finding some kid
like splay it out on the couch yes yeah
yeah he'd been done up but she didn't
laugh about this but it was you know
we're looking back on it it's it's
amusing
rob's laughing again
what is happening we didn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on we just walk in
there and i'm like charlie did you see
that he's like yeah and then there's a
there's a dead kid in the room dead guy
yeah like a maybe like a guy in his 20s
or something and maybe not dead i mean i
we didn't take his pulse i mean maybe he
was in a coffin he was like she wasn't a
coffee i mean he didn't look good yeah
yeah oh boy
that bad and did you have any feelings
about that were or were you already by
that time again you know just a little
too sort of dead inside i was i was
definitely confused mostly confused as
to why we were in the situation that we
were in belatedly amused you know like
not amused
at the moment terrified at the moment
and then after the fact being you know
like
that was odd yeah well i'll tell you the
the body that's
the body that i found in fairmount park
was not amusing but there was an amusing
anecdote that is associated with it
where i called the police as you do when
you find a dead human
corpse right and the cop came over and
he was across the street when so we had
crossed the street and i was just
standing there and i'm looking at the
body and he pulls up he's like yeah you
want to call him my cat he's like what
do you want i'm like there's a dead body
over there he looks at he goes nah
that's just a bunch of clothes
and i was like no that's a that's a body
i went over to it and i saw it as his
and i'm telling yous
[Laughter]
it's a bunch of clothes young man
that's just a bunch of clothes i'm like
no no no it's not a bunch of clothes
it's not and he goes over to it and i
just [ __ ] [ __ ] you not and i have a
witness chris murray was with me chris
murray and i are watching this and the
cop picks up a stick and he pushes the
clothes around to see the body and then
he comes back over and he goes ah that's
a dead body
i was like hey that's what you do in the
gang finds a dead guy you poke him with
the uh actually
it's both it's a dead body and a bunch
of clothes
[Music]
that's very sad
[Music]
i got a question for you guys do you
have any particularly amusing
underage drinking stories of your own or
how about this more specifically
charlie do you remember the first time
you ever got drunk or the first time you
ever
drank uh
i don't not necessarily remember the
first time i ever drank but i do
remember the first time that my buddies
and i got like our hands on a bunch of
beer you know i think there was like
sips of beers here and there that i
can't remember but
there was a mormon church down the
street from me and there was never
anyone there because i don't think
there's a lot of mormons in rhode island
there was like um like a pit with like
machines like air conditioner units and
things that we were like well no one's
gonna see us down there this will be a
great place to get drunk into a pit yeah
so
we we got our hands on like charlie
let's go in this pit yeah yeah like a
like a 24 pack or whatever of of natty
lights oh yeah yeah and we got we got
down in the pit and we just got hammered
son on those natty lights oh yeah give
us the accent come on we li
i love it i just did and then um and
then it's like
we're just down there drinking beers you
know me and the boys what was that
experience like for were you like oh wow
i really like this or were you like oh
wow i'm just dizzy i don't feel well how
did it how did you react to it i think
actually that was the first time we had
a good time like i think there was other
scenario i've been in scenarios where i
had like a beer there was like nervous
about getting sick or whatever
really always scared to get sick was my
oh
so it kind of helped me off on drinking
for a while like sick as in like oh i'm
going to drink too much and throw up
like a scene in there yeah he's
terrified to throw up because you've
seen that in the movies or because you'd
felt it no because i knew that was
something that could happen uh-huh but
yeah i don't i don't recall i do
remember my one friend my youngest
friend who's too young to be with us
drinking
getting very sick from drinking too much
and that and i felt guilty about that i
still feel guilty about it tell the
truth
okay well i think you can let that one
go buddy i think you can let that one go
i don't know i was the oldest you know
field manager yeah you felt that
responsibility a little bit a little bit
rob what about you man do you remember
the first time you've ever gotten i want
to say i appreciate you trying to find
some structure to put into these
podcasts because i i'm just having fun
buddy you know somebody's got to keep
this train on the rails you know what i
mean otherwise yeah i'll tell you what
the first time i got really really drunk
was at lemon hill and i know exactly
what we were doing we were drinking
saint ides oh 40s wow because you know
you're like
you know it was just a huge part of the
culture at the time because we were all
watching like gangster rap videos and
[ __ ] well some more bang for your buck
they're higher in alcohol content
but i never understood your hands and
you would get they would get warm so
unless you drank them really fast yeah
so we drank that sainides really fast
and i drank two of them and i probably
weighed 102 pounds oh my god and i got
violently ill and we took the subway we
had to take a train and then and then
the elevated train like the subway and
puked all over the tree
all over the train how old are you
13. ah
guys listen too young it's too young way
too young listeners if you get a chance
go online and try to look at some
younger pictures of rob mcelhoney there
is a great youtube video of him in an
anti-smoking ad where he looks about 13
or 14 years old and i believe you were
what 20 20 21 yeah 21.
the guy didn't hit puberty until he was
in his mid-20s yeah it took a while it
took
over compensatory i cannot wait is it
good is it good to i cannot wait to hit
it
it's fun right like you're getting uh
it's it's a transition the voice drops
it has its ups and downs i cannot wait
no i don't think if those hormones
haven't kicked in uh by now charlie
they're coming i don't think you got
them i just don't think you have
whatever organs produce those things
um you need more leaks are you guys
gonna ask me my my story that's fine now
moving
i i was trying to get charlie's
attention but he was doing it naturally
and it was great i couldn't
yeah
i was not at all
i know you weren't i know you weren't
that's why i brought it up because i was
like these [ __ ] guys are so focused
on themselves they're not gonna they
don't even give a [ __ ] it's not that i
didn't
yeah well that's true i feel like we
just finished this story we were just it
was that no that totally totally i was
like he saw that he saw the writing on
the wall well we were we were
transitioning out yeah glenn when was
the first time you went out and got and
and had some drinks and got drunk oh
gosh it's funny that you should ask wait
we're telling stupid stories from when
we were underage yeah which is the okay
the theme of the that is this episode
can you tell the story about when you
hung yourself by accident because this
is the dumbest thing i've ever heard a
person yeah that's right i've forgotten
this this one is nice
i was on a church camp it was a two-week
long church camp and it was actually
really really fun and it was out in the
woods and you know we were bunks and it
was super [ __ ] great anyway there was
this prayer groups and games and
hangings
[Laughter]
uh yeah most of it was fun and then
there were moments where they were
preaching at us and it was like well
this is i'll tolerate this because the
rest of it's fun
there was a barn on the grounds there's
like an old barn that i think was
probably there from before this was even
a camp and the barn was decorated with
all kinds of old-timey western stuff
right like skeletons and things and you
know whatever all kinds of like barn
equipment and [ __ ]
i don't know [ __ ] about barnes uh but
there was also it with the in one spot i
i [ __ ] you not god no why was this there
i don't know there was a noose hanging
from the ceiling okay and so me and my
buddy thought you know what would be
really funny let's jump up let's grab
the noose
and let's hold it and make it look like
we're hanging right and so he did it and
i was like ah that's really funny
looking and then i did it and he was
like yeah that's really funny looking
and then he did it again and i was like
let me go get somebody and and we'll be
like i'll be like oh [ __ ] josh i hung
himself oh my god
yeah funny stuff guys and so i went and
i got somebody and i was like
you got to come in here it's awful josh
is hanging he hung himself and so i you
know run in with the person and then
josh would be there like hanging from
the thing from his hands but under his
neck
and you know with a big goofy look on
his face like so that you know right
away that it's not real it was a joke so
then i did it and josh ran and got
something glenn hung himself going on
himself
and we did this back and forth like
quite a few times then at one point like
he came running in with somebody and my
hands were by my side
and i was hanging from the noose from my
neck and he actually
[ __ ] his pants
he told me this later he was like dude
when i saw that poopoo actually came out
of my butt and i [ __ ] my pants like he
actually [ __ ] his pants
his friend killed himself because he
thought his face
so he ran he runs over and i don't know
how he was able to do this because it
was pretty high off the ground
he moved a table under me and then he
grabbed me by my legs somehow hoisted me
off out of the noose
i fell and slammed against the t he told
me this later i slammed my head against
the table and then he ran and got help
and while he was gone i woke up
and i remember like you know that
feeling when you get up too fast and you
kind of it goes black for a second and
then everything goes back and you feel
like you're going to pass out it was
like that but times a million
and i finally came to and i was in a
room laying on a table alone i had no
[ __ ] idea where i was or what had
happened and long story short i was fine
they took me to the doctor and i was
like what happened like i had my i was
holding on to a thing and he goes oh you
you pressed on a nerve or cut off an
artery in your head cut off your yeah
your carotid
arteries yeah yeah so i think i choked
myself out yeah i choked myself out and
then my arms just dropped i mean if josh
hadn't come in yeah he saved your life
he saved my life praise jesus
[Music]
what's high school like for you guys
good good experience yeah i [ __ ]
nailed it you nailed it was high school
we were thriving in high school no i
don't know i didn't feel like anyone's
thriving high school somebody does
somebody asked oh oh yeah they were
yeah man i had fun in high school but
the puberty thing was tough but then
once i did catch up like my senior year
of high school i had a good time did
people think you were somebody's like
little brother i did that very classic
thing where when you are insanely
insecure you completely you become very
gregarious yeah i became like really
seemed like self-confidence which was
just like arrogance which was masking
and why is it that when once you did go
through puberty that didn't go away yeah
well because it became an indelible part
of my personality ah yeah and i don't
think you can scrape that
you know what i mean i'm still i'm
working on it and glenn high school for
you you were you were like middle of the
pack you like a lot of friends not so
many friends uh
i had i i was lots of girls what we're
not was not getting the girls
when glenn was a senior in high school
his girlfriend was a freshman
no that's not true she was a sophomore
sophomore i was pretty close yeah pretty
close yeah it's okay um
she was my first love rob so go ahead
and make fun of it all you want i really
love that girl i wasn't making fun of it
at all i feel like you were worried
about it i feel like you were there's
that obnoxious [ __ ] thing that you
never grew out of
um
i don't know high school more coffee for
you man me okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah you gotta you're going dark man no
i i like it i know it's good
it's like uh he's playing rolling yeah
it's a roller coaster well i told you
guys i think i might be mildly bipolar
yeah yeah right would you rather me go
drop into the depression face no no no
no no no no no no no let's keep the
mania now okay all right let's go uh
let's go you know what we should do we
should have a segment of the podcast
where we try to guess
which
part glenn's at is he at the mania or
the depression am i at the fulcrum or am
i right
i don't know i had a good time in high
school i was definitely not like
the most popular kid at all or even
close but i wasn't unpopular either i
managed to kind of skate by but i i
remember me and my closest friends
jody and mark our whole thing was we
liked hanging out with everybody when
like the jocks were having a party we'd
go to that party and if like the uh you
know the kids who listen to the cure and
[ __ ] when they would have a party we
went to that [ __ ] party because they
were fun as [ __ ] too we just wanted to
go to all the parties basically we
wanted to go to all the parties and we
liked the girls in every single segment
of the population in school we just we
just wanted to hang out man what year
did that start we just wanted a year or
sophomore year year going sophomore year
yeah every year yeah sophomore year
right away here's a fun fact too glenn
told me the name of his high school
sometime in early 20s
and he told me the name i couldn't
believe it i thought he was joking i
could not believe that this was the name
of his high school it's still and then
he that's crazy and that he couldn't
understand why i couldn't believe that
the name of his high school is the name
of his high school glenn you want to
reveal rob they didn't do the job put it
this way growing up in montgomery
alabama they didn't exactly do a good
job of teaching us the realities of the
uh
what went on in the civil war right
i don't think it really it's not very
proud history in many ways in alabama
you know and that's not me look i mean
but at the time you had no idea even who
the guy was right i'm not i i will you
were 100 not a hundred percent no no i i
knew who he was but i hadn't really put
much thought into it and and i am
admittedly
when it comes to any subject in this
world the worst at history without a
doubt without a doubt i never cared
about history i hated history never
found it [ __ ] interesting always
found it boring as [ __ ] so there's a lot
of [ __ ] that i did jim crow academy prep
pretty close oh my god how did you get
maybe worse maybe worse yeah yeah uh
jefferson davis
high school
charlie have anything to say about that
you don't know who he is either oh
that's a good point
hey you know
aren't paying attention at all
in in history no i didn't pay attention
to the attention and i
will hear it i will learn it i will
understand it i will walk out the door
and delete all the files because they're
just weighing me down man it's boring
i got [ __ ] to do you know like i can't
be going around like thinking about
every single name and date it's crazy no
i'm encountering enough people in my
life that i actually interact with that
i need to know their names i don't need
to know about them out of the classroom
some dude's trying to [ __ ] throw me
in a bush because i'm short and i'm like
and you're wait a second wait a second i
remember the names and dates of every
birthday in the civil war right like
that's not gonna serve me no no no
you're gonna get thrown deeper into the
bush yeah yeah for knowing i got to be
thinking like i'm constantly
strategizing out there just don't know
stuff nerd yeah excuse me feel small
that's dangerous for me
facts say i'd even get the word facts
right
came out with sex this has been fun guys
i really enjoyed taking this trip down
memory memory lane with you oh [ __ ]
sake that's the coffee wearing off
that's the coffee wearing god damn it i
only get i get that it's like a little
short window of time where i'm at full
operational speed and then it's just all
and then so what you go you go zero to
ten and then ten to zero yeah it's all
day for me baby i think you go from like
zero into the green
then into the red for a minute right i
redline and then somewhere lower than
zero well yeah cause i've burned myself
out haven't i i think so yeah i'm
loading up i'm here on gas i'm low on
oil
and uh you know everything starts
rubbing well what's the oil in this
scenario because the gas is the caffeine
the gas is the caffeine the oil is the
cocaine
okay okay it really lubricates things
rob do you have any closing words for us
uh would you like to say something
inspirational to our audience
no okay
uh charlie would you like to
lift people up before they sure um look
you gotta take life day by day you know
just get out there and and just just
worry about today don't worry about too
much tomorrow and uh and uh chin up [ __ ]
up you know and uh believe in yourself
and uh
you know the podcast unless you're an
idiot unless you're an idiot in which
case learn something before you believe
in yourself because if you're a [ __ ]
idiot you really shouldn't believe in
yourself you should believe in the
person who's not an idiot guys this
episode is brought to you by education
education
[ __ ] please get one
[Applause]
you